Here's how to think of brand new
original ideas reading the same books
that everyone else does. It's a tactic
that I call hybrid reading. Instead of
reading one book at a time, you read
six, seven, or eight books at a time. I
know it sounds a little bit crazy, but
it actually works together. So, like
right here I have a bunch of books that
I'm reading. I could be reading The
Psychology of Money, Project Hail Mary
by Andy Weir. I also could be reading
Calendar of Wisdom by Leo Tolstoy, or
some [music] fiction by Brandon
Sanderson, or some other fiction,
Yellowface, or a book about status,
right? I'm reading [music] 10 books at
any given time, and what I do is
whatever I feel like reading is the book
that I pick up. [music]
Whether it's 10 pages or 15 pages or
anything, and you go through them
slower, but you start to connect ideas
between those books that should have
never gone together, right? Some sort of
character arc from the Brandon Sanderson
book paired with a psychology of money
tactic. I start to pair those things
together, [music] and I create a brand
new idea by connecting them. So, hybrid
reading, try that, give that a go. And
if you missed it,